[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta nueva
visión de los observadores de france 24
esta semana nos vamos hasta canadá para
un programa especial dedicado a los
inuit donde dos activistas han recurrido
a texto para mostrar la cultura y la
vida cotidiana de sus pueblos indígenas
cada uno con un punto de vista muy
particular
dyn
se acabó
cenar en un iglú cazar en la vaquita va
a enfrentarse a la larga noche polar del
invierno en tick tock o profesor y no y
publica vídeos desde tallo la una aldea
de mil habitantes en night but en el
extremo norte de canadá
él cuenta como losing y sigue enviando
sus tradiciones y su cultura pero
también su vida cotidiana en esta región
nuestra comunidad es tan remota y está
tan aislada que no tenemos carreteras
así que la única forma de conseguir
alimentos es por avión y por eso los
precios son tan altos
en un bar
que se activó
y es una de las razones por las que sigo
practicando la casa
y otras razones porque los alimentos que
obtenemos en nuestra tierra son mucho
más saludables que los que conseguimos
en el supermercado
[Música]
durante el invierno lo más grande que
podemos cazar son las focas
son como regalos de los animales para
nosotros y no deberían sufrir de ninguna
manera
[Música]
y llevamos miles de años viviendo de la
carne de oso polar es parte de nuestra
cultura de nuestra herencia
wyss y por eso cuando vamos a cazar osos
polares por ejemplo vemos entre 20 y 40
osos y solo se nos permite cazar uno
ellos tenían que usar muchos los iglúes
hace mucho tiempo porque para dormir
afuera hacen 50 grados bajo cero y
adentro de 5 a 10 grados
el iglú que mostré mi tick tock está a
unos 5 minutos a pie del pueblo y en mi
look que mostré es para que la comunidad
se reúna y muestre cómo vivían los
inuits hace mucho tiempo a partir de
finales de mayo el sol nunca se pone
más
[Aplausos]
y los niños empiezan a salir más
empiezan a estar afuera toda la noche y
la hora no hace ninguna diferencia y el
gobierno canadiense nos ayuda a salir
del ártico
por lo que siento orgullo en mi país
a la baja
no más
este vídeo muestra una interpretación de
canto de garganta inuit que suele ser
realizada por dos mujeres
esta tradición estuvo en peligro de
desaparecer tras ser prohibida durante
décadas por los colonos y misioneros de
canadá nuestra observadora china no va
linda comparte este tipo de vídeos el
dictó para preservar esta práctica pero
también para dar a conocer la cultura
hindú y entre sus 2.3 millones de
seguidores el fin definitivamente fue mi
mamá quien me animó a publicar este
vídeo en first y desde entonces ha
tenido muchas vistas a mucha gente le
encantó y fue entonces cuando continúe
publicando vídeos culturales
[Risas]
[Música]
hay clases y muchos comentarios
negativos pero creo que con el tiempo la
gente se acostumbró mucho más y empezó a
apreciar nuestra cultura cuando les
explico lo que significa para nosotros e
intento educar a la gente a través de
mis plataformas no mucha gente es
consciente de que los pueblos indígenas
todavía existen aquí hoy en día no mucha
gente sabe que canadá también tiene una
historia oscura que no es un país
perfecto y que todavía hay muchas
mejoras que hacer y que todavía
necesitamos que se escuche nuestra voz
pues este hubiera caído cuando ustedes
masacraron a todos nuestros wikis o de
cuando se llevaron a nuestros niños a
internados para usar de ellos de todas
las formas posibles o cuando nos dijeron
que dejáramos de hablar nuestra lengua y
de practicar nuestra cultura como el
canto de garganta en nuestros tatuajes y
todas esas cosas
eso no es oscuro eso no de ser racistas
eso está bien eso fue hace como 60 años
mis abuelos pasaron por todos
[Música]
sin dictó que existe esta comunidad
indígena y todos nos apoyamos mutuamente
desde diferentes partes del mundo
así que creo que es realmente importante
utilizar estas plataformas para
finalmente hablar y animar a los jóvenes
a quererse a sí mismos tal y como sólo
estén absorción y es así que publicar en
las redes sociales es educar y ayudar a
nuestros jóvenes a sentirse incluidos
también
es algo que no teníamos antes
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa por esta semana recuerde que
esperamos sus fotos y videos aficionados
para contar la historia de su lado del
lado de la gente hasta pronto
[Música]